- [Narrator] $10 billion, then
47 billion, then 100 billion.
The Adani Group's seven listed companies
have plummeted in market
value after a report
from short seller
Hindenburg Research accused
the conglomerate of wide ranging fraud.
The Adani Group, headed by
billionaire Gautam Adani,
said The report is full
of baseless allegations.
Ben Foldy covers financial
and business issues
for The Wall Street Journal
and explains what you need to know.
- The Adani Group is a
collection of companies.
They run ports, they run airports,
they run coal-powered power
plants, they run coal terminals.
Basically all the things
that you kind of need
to build a fast growing,
developing economy like India,
and Hindenburg Research looks
for companies that they allege
are frauds or have accounting issues,
and they then bet against the stock,
and then they publish the research
showing their allegations,
hoping that it will go down.
They were largely responsible
for almost everything that happened
with a company called Nikola,
which led to the founder being indicted
on fraud charges and convicted last year
in one of the biggest cases of
that type in recent history.
Hindenburg's allegations about Adani
are largely around a network
of offshore companies that they allege
are tied to the Adani family
or their associates that they
use to manipulate the stock.
- The report is a malicious combination
of selective misinformation,
stale, baseless
and discredited allegations
that have been tested
and rejected by India's highest codes.
- Adani responded with a 413-page report.
What was interesting about
the response is that it opened
on this note of Indian
nationalism, which really kind
of points to a defense
strategy for the company
but also, it points to
the company's identity
as being part and parcel
of the Indian growth story.
- The fundamentals of our
company are very strong.
Our balance sheet is
healthy and assets robust.
We will continue to focus
on a long-term value creation and growth.
- Adani has already suffered quite a bit.
$100 billion in market cap
is nothing to sneeze at.
To have something move
the market this much
within a couple days is pretty remarkable.
(pensive music)